RESTRICTIONS ON RESTAURANTS AND
BARS OF THE NEW YEAR’S HOLIDAYS.
AND TEXAS ATTORNEY KEN PAXTON
JOINS US NOW.
WHY DO YOU WANT TO PUSH BACK
THESE RESTRICTIONS AT THE MAYOR
IS IMPOSING?
>> IT’S THE MAYOR AND THE COUNTY
JUDGE BECAUSE THEY ARE AND
DIRECT -- HE’S ALREADY
RESTRICTED BARS AND RESTAURANTS
TO EAT EITHER A 75% OR 50%
OCCUPANCY BUT HE SAID YOU CANNOT
HAVE RESTRICTIONS ON TIME.
SO THEY KIND OF TRY TO SNEAK
THIS INTO DAYS AGO AND THEY ARE
GOING TO STOP AND BECAUSE IT’S
IN VIOLATION OF STATE LAW.
>> Sandra: SO THAT’S WHY HE
SAID THESE RESTRICTIONS WERE
NECESSARY AND BACKS UP THE
AUSTIN MAYOR DOING THIS.
THEY PUT THEM IN BARS ON
NEW YEAR’S EVE AND PACKED THEM
TOGETHER FOR HOURS, THE
PRODUCTION WILL BE OVERWHELMING
AND HAVE BEEN VERY QUICKLY.
ARE YOU CHOOSING TO SAY THAT
THAT’S NOT THE CASE, IGNORE IT
OR ARE YOU JUST SAYING IT’S TIME
TO OPEN BUSINESSES?
WHAT DO YOU SAVE BACK TO THE
HEALTH OFFICIALS WHO SAY THAT?
>> MY JOB IS TO AND FORCE
WHATEVER THE LAW IS.
THEY ARE JUST OPERATING ON THEIR
OWN UNDER TEXAS LAW SO MY JOB IS
NOT TO DECIDE WHAT THE BEST
POLICY IS BUT TO ENFORCE THE LAW
LAW.
SO HAVING THEIR CURFEW ON
RESTAURANTS PROBABLY WON’T MAKE
MUCH OF A DIFFERENCE EVEN THOUGH
THIS PARTICULAR DOCTOR, IT WON’T
AFFECT MUCH OF ANYTHING.
>> Sandra: THE GOVERNOR OF
TEXAS SAYS THE BAN AS ILLEGAL AS
WELL, THE SHUTDOWN OF AUSTIN IS
NOT ALLOWED.
THE STOPS CITIES LIKE AUSTIN
FROM ARBITRARILY SUCH AS
SHUTTING DOWN BUSINESSES AND
THEIR CITY’S RESPONSIBILITY TO
ENFORCE EXISTING ORDERS AND NOT
MAKE NEW ONES.
HE OF COURSE IS RESPONDING TO
THE AUSTIN MAYOR WHO SAYS THIS.
>> WE HAVE TAKEN LIMITED ACTION
TO ARREST IN THESE CASES.
IF WE DON’T TAKE ACTION NOW,
BUSINESSES WILL SUFFER EVEN
MORE, FAMILIES WILL SUFFER AND
ARE A WAY OF LIFE WILL SUFFER
AND IT WILL TAKE US
EXPONENTIALLY LONGER TO RETURN
TO LIFE THAT IS NORMAL.
>> Sandra: I KNOW YOU HAD GONE
AS FAR AS TO SUGGEST THAT THESE
LEADERS SUCH AS THE MAYOR OF
AUSTIN HAS CONTEMPT FOR TEXANS
AND THE LOCAL BUSINESSES THERE.
>> I THINK HE DOES, AND I HE
DOESN’T HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO DO
WHAT HE’S DOING.
HE DOESN’T HAVE ANY AUTHORITY TO
DO THAT WHEN THE GOVERNOR HAS
SPECIFICALLY SET OUT GUIDELINES
FOR THE ENTIRE STATE.
IF HE WANTS TO GO THROUGH THE
CORRECT PROCESS AND CALL THE
GOVERNOR AND SAY HEY, I THINK WE
SHOULD CHANGE THIS, AND THE
GOVERNOR DECIDES TO DO THAT,
THAT’S HOW THE PROCESS WORKS,
NOT JUST THE LOCAL MAYOR
DECIDING TO MAKE UP NEW RULES
FOR HIS CITY AND PUTTING CURFEW
ON THE RESTAURANTS.
>> OBVIOUSLY THEY FOLLOW THIS
AND PUT THIS OUT ON THE 29TH, WE
WILL TAKE IT ALL THE WAY TO THE
TEXAS SUPREME COURT IF WE HAVE
TO.
THE END WE WILL BE SUCCESSFUL
BECAUSE A LAW LAW IS PRETTY
CLEAR.
>> Sandra: I KNOW YOU LOVE
TEXAS AND I KNOW YOU LOVE THE
PEOPLE THERE.
HOW BAD HAS THE ECONOMY BEEN HIT
ON THESE RESTRICTIONS?
>> IT’S BEEN TOUGH.
IT’S SAD FOR ME TO SEE THAT,
BECAUSE PEOPLE HAVE NO CONTROL
OVER HOW IT AFFECTS THEIR JOBS.
AT THIS POINT WE GET BACK TO THE
DECISION-MAKING AT AN INDIVIDUAL
LEVEL BECAUSE THAT’S WHAT IS
BEST FOR YOUR HEALTH AND THEIR
JOBS IN THESE SITUATIONS.
>> Sandra: IT’S QUITE
SOMETHING TO WATCH AS WE WRAP
THIS YEAR, 2020.
WE JUST GOT DONE WITH THE
SEGMENT WHERE THE DOCTOR GOT
THAT VACCINATED AND WHAT MORE